what do you think happens when we die
keanu reeves
i know that the ones who love us will
miss us
[Music]
if you're a lover you got to be a
fighter
because if you don't fight for your love
what kind of love do you have i'm a
pretty simple guy
you know um
you know ever since i was a young kid i
wanted to act
you know i started professional acting
when i was 15.
um
and you know i've been really lucky to
have the chance to have a career
and
i don't know i just have always tried to
keep it simple
you know i think it's just in my nature
you know sometimes i go to the afternoon
movie alone
[Music]
he's the matrix guy that's some
over-the-top fame he hit that johnny
depp tom cruise level of fame and then
just became this super chill mellow guy
that can just like go through crowds
that guy goes sits on the subway by
himself well there's no obvious outward
displays of wealth from him and he's
insanely wealthy
you're turning 50 this year oh yes i am
how do you feel about growing older uh
it's fantastic glad to be here
you're not worried about aging or of
course yeah aging means death yeah i'm
totally freaked out i don't see me i am
but uh you know
it's
it's okay
life is amazing life can be amazing take
me back to beirut
september 1964. you're born right beirut
lebanon yeah the paris of the middle
east my mother and father were like 21
22. my father was there he had gotten i
actually don't really know his story
[Music]
but anyway so they met they fell in love
they had a baby
that was me then they split up
we went to new york
and then i went up in toronto there were
a series of things that happened in
canada before you came to la right like
you did a little theater and you did a
little television i was really
self-motivated so i was taking classes
you know i really enjoyed the
shakespeare in high school so i i got
involved with a jewish community center
that had a drama program
uh run by the remarkable rose dubin and
uh i ended up playing mercutio and a
production of romeo and juliet and one
of the other actors had an agent
um they asked if i had any
representation i said no
and so that's really where the
professional thing started
you know when you start out you just
especially when i well whenever you
start out in something you have hopes
and you have dreams
uh for me it was
um just getting the chance to act and to
to i know i knew i wanted to make movies
and i knew i wanted to go to hollywood
to to be in films you know i got in my
car when i was 20 years old and i drove
to los angeles and
um you know i had been working i got an
agent and but i didn't know
i mean you can never know what your life
is going to be um
and so
i you know i don't know again i just
kind of
feel grateful to
to be here my career i've had a lot of
people disagree with me
[Laughter]
but uh i'm okay with that and i think um
you know i think that's part of the
collaboration there's these things that
we oftentimes we have responsibilities
and so we'll make sacrifices you know or
we'll be attracted to something and
we'll make sacrifices to get something
we have to be thoughtful about that
you know that you can sometimes
um
sacrifice yourself that you think it's
for the good but maybe there's another
way how does keanu reeves uh deal with
anxiety
breathe
yeah you gotta breathe try to
figure out why are you afraid what does
that mean and then um
try and
yeah try to
just
be
and and let not what you're afraid of
define the
the present that you hope to be in when
you go do what you're afraid of
[Music]
i found this phenomenon the sad keanu
where people are taking a photo of you
sitting on a bench eating a sandwich
looking a little bit sad but so many
people are worried about your welfare
um no i think that's lovely but um
no the i i think it was people started
to do funny things with that um
sad keanu
but uh you're not sad i'm well yeah no
i'm normal we all go through phases of
happy and sad
[Music]